let's give a warm Arizona welcome to
your gubernatorial candidate Republican
Kerry Lake
to see you thanks for coming appreciate
it
hello how are you very enthusiastic
you drew a crowd no I think they came
for you you're running for election I
did offer to buy them bribe them with
In-N-Out Burger though oh that that'll
bring a crowd that was my favorite place
Welcome to Arizona thank you for soon to
be Governor right I think uh
I never take anything for granted though
I mean I've seen you up as high as five
six points in the polls but I tell that
every candidate you have to run like
you're behind yep you know it's two
minutes left in the game no timeouts
you're on your own 20. you got to March
down the field 80 yards you gotta cross
the plane kick the field goal to win is
that how you're running you're speaking
my language my dad was a football coach
and we are we are with seconds left on
the clock right now we have 15 days left
in this election and we are acting like
we're 20 points back but we've been
doing that since day one because we knew
that we have to save this state and you
know we we know from the crowds that
we're getting that we are way ahead we
have we drew 4 000 people at a rally
Saturday night it was a great event some
of you might have been there right
that's amazing and Katie held her
biggest event and I think there were 20
people there right so I mean I'm not
sure I believe all the polls I know from
what I'm feeling that there's something
going on in Arizona and it's good I hope
hope so now I want to go to this quote
of hers it's ridiculous to focus on the
border
this is a well every state now is a
border state it's ridiculous to focus on
the border she actually said that and
she supports amnesty her plan is to let
Joe Biden handle it Joe Biden is the
reason we've gotten into this mess does
not know today is Monday that's right
we have to wake him up in the middle of
an inner see he fell asleep in the
middle of an interview uh yeah uh what
does Dr Biden think
uh so Mr President and then you look at
her voting record when she was a state
senator and she voted against the border
wall she voted against the virtual
border wall against the Border Strike
Force which would help protect arizonans
and she voted against this is the
Shocker she even voted against asking
the federal government to reimburse us
for the costs that we're incurring I
don't know how she can look herself in
the mirror we have a fentanyl crisis and
I know that she's not talking to that
many people on the campaign Trail but
I'm talking to people every day hundreds
sometimes thousands of people and when
you see a mother come up to you and talk
about losing her son or father her 17
year old son took one pill a 19 year old
son took a half a pill and they're gone
we have to it is the number one killer
of our children now in the country
that's right and it's coming across that
border that she doesn't understand what
we're focused on it and she's an open
borders globalist let's face it she's
she wants to take what Newsome has done
for California which has destroyed that
state and do the same thing here in
Arizona and that's why I think we have a
movement because people know if we elect
someone like Katie Hobbs we're going to
turn into California 2.0 and nobody
wants that I'm pretty safe by the way
you have a lot of Californians moving in
I think there ought to be a rule maybe
if you become governor you get the
legislature to pass a rule you're
allowed to come but you can't ruin the
state the way you ruin the last state
you came from that would be
uh
I don't know how you figure that out
though I will say this though The
Californians are the ones who grabbed me
at these events and go don't let Arizona
go we uprooted our children we uprooted
our business we moved our home we are
here we don't want Arizona to turn into
California so some of our California
friends that moved here they gave up a
lot somebody's waving in the crowd they
don't want this to turn in they flee
they fled California so here's an
amazing thing if you take a U-Haul from
anywhere in California to Texas or
Arizona where we are you know in the
case of Texas it will cost you about 2
500 from California to Texas if you take
that same U-Haul from Texas back to
California you'll pay three or four
hundred dollars you're doing U-Haul a
favor if you negotiate you could
probably get it for free probably U-Haul
which is an Arizona company they will
pay you to get a U-Haul from Arizona to
California because people are moving so
fast let's talk about why will she not
debate you
well she's now missed her chance because
we had the debate last night and it
aired last night it was a great
conversation I didn't yell there was no
antics you know she's afraid there's
several reasons one she has terrible
there's a forum though there's a little
difference yeah last night we just had
an interview because she wouldn't show
up right but she's afraid to defend her
policies because the dead end
destructive policies how do you defend
wanting an open border when you've got
so many fentanyl pills pouring across
that they could kill every man woman and
child in this country how do you defend
that how do you defend your voting
record when you voted nearly 90 percent
of the time against small Arizona
businesses when you had a chance to help
them how do you defend tax increases
that you are pushing for when you were
in the legislature and how do you defend
I think this might have been the worst
bill that she co-sponsored can you
imagine putting your name on a bill and
she did this she co-sponsored a bill
to start sex education in kindergarten
this is the leftist that we're dealing
with and so she knows she would get we
would bring that up on the stage and
we'd bring up her twice convicted you
know racist past she's got a terrible
passage she can't defend it and I think
we just lost twice on the racial
discrimination two juries of her peers
yes a unanimously convicted of racism
and sexism for paying women of color
thirty thousand dollars less than men
and it's always the left accusing
conservatives and Republicans of being
racist and really they're the racist so
one of the big issues the Democrats have
tried to make this campaign about
abortion now I would argue inflation
41-year High record high gas prices wide
open borders a lack of Law and Order
and woke education versus traditional
education are the big issues in her case
and a lot of Democrats are trying to
make abortion but she is somebody that
would support abortion with no
restrictions at all and when asked about
it she wouldn't give any restrictions so
that means she would allow an abortion
up until the moment before birth because
that child is viable outside a mother's
womb that is called where I grew up in
fanocide yep it is it is truly the
murder of a baby you're right you know
we got pressured on this by the media
the fake news in this town is horrible
and they were pressuring me every day on
the trail to talk about abortion and I
said look I'm pro-life I'm I want to
save as many babies as possible I want
to help as many women as possible they
go into a Planned Parenthood they're
given one choice and that is the worst
Choice let's give women options so that
they can choose life they can find a
family that wants to adopt their baby
and then I would say to the press and
you should pin down Katie Hobbs on where
she stands because she's for abortion up
until the moment the baby is born and
then after and they finally did I'm
really proud I think my pressuring of
the fake news pressured them to pin her
down and we got to verify the last
couple of weeks the Press finally asked
her wait a minute she's like Northam and
supports the idea remember the governor
of the Commonwealth of Virginia well
first the baby is born and we'll make
the baby comfortable then the mother
will have a consultation with the doctor
and decide whether this independent
human being gets delivered it's
disgusting yeah her voting record proves
that if you don't believe me look at her
voting record and her voting record
shows when a bill was presented to her
to vote on to save a baby who would
survive an abortion to give them life to
give that baby treatment she voted no
she'd rather the baby die in a cold
metal tray and this is what we're
dealing with here she says she's for tax
cuts but 13 times she had an opportunity
to cut taxes and she did not
how does she say that with a straight
face
I don't know I don't know how she says
well she says a lot of us and all's
because that's how she does
that's how she answers questions Sean
she couldn't even answer a simple
question how was your relationship with
the Hispanic American Community that's a
great question uh uh yeah well the thing
is nobody's asking her these questions
because she's running from the media
she's running from the debate stage she
is only talking to people who are
friendly and throwing softball questions
at her meantime we've taken our we call
the job interview we've taken on the
road and because she wouldn't do the
debate I think of a debate as a job
interview I think everyone's safe to say
the people are the hiring manager
I'm applying for the job Katie's
applying for the job and we go and talk
to the hiring manager the people of
Arizona we talk about what we want to do
for this state they know because they've
heard me that I want to secure the
Border I want to make sure our kids are
getting a decent education not a
brainwashing they want to make sure that
we have a strong economy so that we can
have families who can afford groceries
and gas and vacations even maybe get it
to where it's that good the big issues
that are fundamental I would argue in
every election Beyond inflation and gas
prices and we'll talk about that then it
becomes border security then it becomes
Law and Order everybody wants to be safe
and secure in their town and City and
we're not right right and we're not
right and it's a variety of problems
it's we've got a wide open border five
million people coming in in the last
year 2.3 million have come in that's not
including the godaways the godaways are
the people who come in they want to be
they want to come in undetected because
they have a criminal background 98
apprehended people on our Terror watch
list those are only the people we caught
yes imagine that what who's getting
through that we don't know about that's
what's scary and that's why we've got to
secure the border and and fully fund our
police get all of our police departments
fully funded right
the other thing
that you could have a very big role in
is on the issue of Education now maybe
I'm old-fashioned I don't think that
kindergarten through even sixth grade
should be learning about gender identity
or CRT it's garbage I'm old-fashioned I
believe in Reading Writing math History
Science and computers and the Golden
Rule you can teach the kids you know
love God and your neighbor as yourself
yep if you public school you can't
mention the god part okay treat others
the way you want to be and we do need to
bring God back into our society
our state motto is God enriches God
enriches and we need to Katie house
doesn't even want our state motto in the
classroom probably because the word
God's in there and this is what's
happened when we push God out of our
society out of our culture out of our
homes out of our hearts look what's
happened to America we need to bring God
back we really do and so all right we
got to take a break okay Arizona hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else